also new tonight in the state
legislature ab282 is moving on now this
bill would allow long-term substitute
teachers to have better access to health
insurance it would require school
districts to grant them a monthly
subsidy in order to be used on Health
Care those full-time substitutes would
also have to show proof of purchase of
full-time that's defined as being hired
by the district for 30 consecutive days
or more
Governor Lombardo sponsored Bill for
school safety also passing the full
State Assembly with 38 votes in favor
and only four against it it takes a
harder stance on students involved in
violent or drug-related incidents
students even as young as six years old
could be expelled if it becomes law this
aspect of the bill receiving some
pushback from some of the State Assembly
who don't want policies that create
quote throw away children for this
reason an amendment was added following
an appeals process and route to re-entry
for those students